j'ai dansé un slow avec un chanteur
international dans sa chambre de qui
s'agit-il alors ça pourrait poser la
question s'il est mort on sait que c'est
par la
sexta d'accord voilà comme ça au moins
on avance juifs hommes femmes mais moi
je ne suis pas un flou dans sa chambre
alors que c'est aussi ça la magie kelly
kelly non c'est toi les ballons au
pardon non c'est lisa mary n'ont pas
dire mot zabel avec un chanteur
international d'hôtels mais si ça selon
isabelle sortait un soir m'a dit cela
mais c'est vrai dans mais attendez c'est
vous non ah bon mersana c'est une fille
ou un garçon oui parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui est là ce soir c'est vous
écris c'est pas
gagné mais c'était quelques farida le
coach est ce encore tunisiens
qui avaient non figurez vous que c'est
avec la même personne george clooney non
non non c'est george clooney un morceau
qu'est celle qu'a rencontré matthieu
delormeau coire au lieu des 8 kg bastien
voilà quelques années de ça exactement
c'était à new york pour danser un slow
avait à new york avec roulant la jasse
de tels new yorkaise de couler une
question c'est est-ce que tu foutais
dans la chambre où le
monde avait mangé pas que
[Rires]
l'asie était pas là pour compter les
mozzarellas
je te le dis alors à côté star web un
jeu si j'allais pour l'interview mais
parce qu'il le faisait un spectacle
carnet guillaume grande salle de
spectacle new yorkaise très très très
élégant très chic et c est donc je
devais le rencontrer normalement au
carnegie hall mais on s'était croisé
très vite et visiblement je lui ai plus
ils ce sont trois être
oui et donc il était son attaché de
presse non le fait plus aucun légume au
carnegie hall on le fait à l'hôtel dans
dans la réception de l'hôtel enfin voilà
et une wii ben oui donnerai c'est pas
mon truc sur et une fois qu'on arrive là
il dit non finalement je trouve que
c'est mieux dans ma carrière pour tout
ça dans ma chambre quand on voit là mais
bon les chambres de mes gars c'est pas
juste une chambre et voilà nos malades
et match en main comme donc je suis
monté chaque fois qu'elle fait une
interview ça se termine dans la chambre
du gabon
j'étais jeune et fraîche êtes toujours
je les ferai alors et de bernard leroy
de boulettes
on commence on commence donc on les
installations alors il faut savoir
qu'avec julio iglesias les installations
ça dure des plombes à ce qu'ils veulent
et bonne lumière pour son bon profil etc
et donc moi j'étais tout seul avec juste
un caméraman et lui il était seul avec
son attaché trait à l'époque et donc on
commence à discuter en attendant les
installations et ont discuté puis il
s'avère que je lui dis que ma maman est
fan de lui parce qu'elle sait qu'elle
est énorme et qu'elle s'appelle carotène
et donc on se met à parler en espagnol
et aux idées week ou
mauvais long cours ça crée une proximité
c'est un coup voilà
avec un coup de main on se dit bon bah
c'est bon c'est bon ces prêts et dons
qu'il congédie son attaché de presse le
congé dit il la croire j'ai dit le camp
jeudi et a causé des maux qui lui dit en
gros qui peut aller s manon voilà l'on
parle français et donc et donc on
commence l'interview
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
cette séduction qui s'installe et moi je
suis un peu gêné parce qu'il y en a
quand même une petite déjà une petite
expérience et en même temps et c'est
très très respectueux etc et on se met
vraiment à discuter mais plus du tout de
l'interview dans mon caméraman et un peu
gêné et tout et on commença à parler et
puis je dis mais qu'est ce que c'est qui
écroulent régler cias quiz produits
anglais l'audi 100 web et là il se lève
km h il s'approche de moi il commence à
me chanter vous les femmes
jean-luc avec jacques fath
et dont il me promet vraiment alors
fulvio conti fins un seul os et un slot
on a collé serré quand même donc il me
choque comme ça on est là mon caméraman
c'est plus sylvie laborie des films et
est donc là il m'a alors celle selon
vous les femmes vous serrer dans une
chambre d'hôtel et il m'a chanté
quelques chansons dans l'oréal en jour
c'est vrai vous aussi tout ce bonheur et
tais-toi et collés serrés ans et après
il mais je me suis assise et vous a fait
la même chose à bruay
[Rires]
vous les femmes
il continue quand il faut et il m'a
répondu donc à ma question il m'a dit
c'est ça une règle sinon j'aime bien
et
alors que j'ai fait une interview avec
toutes les voix j'avais un chapeau sur
la tête quarante cinq fois dans
l'interview il s'amuse nbc le chapeau
sur les dieux je le rôle belle l'europe
et saint nazaire et 45 cents voyez vous
la réussite est regardée
[Applaudissements]
j'ai hurlé moins fort simplement jill
ces chiens mais c'est vrai alors l
entend oui cette oreille là en tout cas
j'entends glacée de mon copain pardon
savent maintenant des mercis alors voilà
j'ai eu un gros accident devant une star
du rap ça je pense que c'est vraiment à
l'instar du rappeur d'y croire et mon
nom sans moi
a toujours pas annoncé dimanche qu'ils
allaient alors que gilles verdez non
lordon
c'est moi ouais en fait quand j'étais
petit j'animais une émission de radio
sur le rap sur une radio locale qui
s'appelle radio laser et à 14 ans radio
radio laser à 14 ans j'ai eu la chance
d'interviewer booba banon est en fait
quand je me suis retrouvé face à lui
j'étais tellement stressée tellement
impressionné que j'ai fait dans mon mène
une faute et c'est exactement à ce
moment là
un accident de voiture non vous êtes
feature et la grâce et le l'as nancy
buman en garde jean baptiste eyraud il
venait de chez dessus
en fait j'écoute il avait rien n'est pas
en tout cas dans l'année
[Rires]
en fait non mais j'ai cru qu'il avait
rien senti et quand je suis parti c'est
lui qui regardait sous ses semelles
comme ça
c'est drôle c'est comme le c7 castaldi
j'ai un sujet assister la rupture entre
madonna et son mec ça c'est ça c'est ça
c'est vous c'est sûr qu'elle sénat
marché russe était sur la whey bah c'est
sûr parce qu ils détiennent rupture elle
est là bas
déclare rupture ou amauri les latences
la tâte u2 c'est une arrive tout de
suite allé d'un but d'éviter
alors son mec c'est sean penn
et stylos
à l'étang oui un été à miami et
j'accompagnais le collier ce n'était pas
besoin
j'adore c'est bin moi j'en passe donc
j'étais à miami j'accompagnais nino
cerruti
le couturier nino cerruti chez un dîner
chez jack nicholson ou cheyrou tire
odyssée inouïe et d'orge accompagné
dîner chez jack nicholson qui est
habillée par cerruti tarare est de
sortir ses quatre compagnons nino
cerruti chez jack nicholson
[Applaudissements]
l'histoire est à bichât
il accompagne et patric chiha michel
cymes
[Applaudissements]
7 nico c'est vrai c'était un grand dîner
tourner un film actuellement jack
nicholson tourner un film à miami et il
se trouve qu'au téléphone sean penn
était déjà avec quelqu'un est une jeune
fille arrive en disant il ya madonna au
téléphone qui veut te par les médias me
fait chier je pu lui parler elle a
appelé toute la soirée un moment il me
dit ça t'amuse de parler à madonna dit
oui je connais pas ce à dire que les
cépages sean penn ni jack nicholson vous
avez par la madonna ah oui ah bah oui
c'est grave
non c'est genre j'ai pas je veux pas te
parler
schlick vous a parlé de vidéo gag
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ding ding allait vraiment richir elle
est honnête je serais moi ça m'a amusé
et lui ça va musée après midi vas-y toi
je n'ai pas lu par les hôtels c'était
fini il était déjà avec une autre
actrice non
ça va québec après
qu'ils aient fait leur donc magnifique
c'est robin ouailles magnifique alors m
et au calme au tos to play ll était
désagréable
et la chine nous regarde
bien sûr qu'il nous regarde et comment
vous avez la fda bonita
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai été le sextoy d'un ministre
isabelle
répulse a failli mais non c'est pas dit
ça peut être alors
je foutais pour cause un certain des
ministres bah séparément
c'est en fait c'est moi cyril
[Applaudissements]
tu sais tu es pendant halloween
[Rires]
s'est étonné que ça vous étonne dans la
musique de
céret mettez le sextoy d'une ministre
d'un ministre danois y campe un homme
curieuse méthode
sommes en moldavie accises hinault en
transit
à l'époque j'étais journaliste de sport
je me baladais beaucoup j'étais en
transit une nuit dans un hôtel en
moldavie intestines je fais un room
service si j'attendais une équipe de
foot qui ne venaient pas je fais room
service dans ma chambre à 22h30 23h sa
toque dans la chambre donc j'ouvre comme
ça je savais pas qui c'était et je vois
deux grand balèze genre gardes du corps
qui ne parlent dans un mauvais anglais
et qui me disent de venir avec eux un
étage aux deux étages plus on monte dans
les tâches des suites comme tout bouffer
le but
exactement ça d'accord les kane par ce
biais on arrive dans une suite comme
quoi merci aux gays
donc moi q
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
vous ne croyez pas si bien dire mais
est donc en fait on arrive à une suite
les deux gammes ouvre et là les deux
gars s'efface j'entre et je vois
quelqu'un que je ne connais pas du tout
arrivé en mars elle et caleçons c'était
boulanger de lille ii était boulanger de
l'hôtel ces moments là je vois là la
figure du gars qui se décompose y avait
sur la table une enveloppe avec plein de
dollars non je vois la figure du gars
qui se décompose immer hurle dessus je
comprends pas ce qui me dit mme parlant
moldave il appelle ses gardes du corps
il me foute tous dehors il m'expulse
dehors je retourne dans ma chambre je
comprends pas et en fait le personnel de
l'hôtel est venu me voir après il avait
inversé ma chambre avec celle d'une
escort girl est prévue à ce ministre
blais c'est sûr que quand nous attendait
mais les gardes du corps exemple un peu
la pente ne sont pas dit
regardez comment s'en sort ils ont du
chien il a quand même des bouchons
[Rires]
les valets je donne le prénom valerio
annonce un ministre de l'économie la
banane ou
[Rires]
à un gain j'ai vu là bistouquette d'un
célèbre didier
kelly s'est dit
non c'est déjà 4 elle dit non mais là il
voit passer j'ai vu l'étendue de mes
bagages at-on dit quand on commence par
j'ai vu on sait que c'est pas castaldi
vraiment vraiment oui ça c'est vrai
ouais c'est moi ce mois à l'époque on
avec cyril et
j'ai un truc je suis rino fob quand je
suis dans les urinoirs dès qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui se bat côté ou à droite ou
à gauche c'est fini je bloquais à mansle
et là j'ai un petit monsieur qui se met
à côté de moi dont je suis bloqué et on
était dans une grande soirée sur paris à
montmartre qu'on avait gratté déplace
chez fun radio tu t'en le petit par judy
c'est bon je vais pouvoir faire pipi
j'ai un peu comme vous je n'aime pas
quand les gens font pipi à côté de moi
le petit par gilles c'est bon je passais
des toilettes et là je me dis vite
dépêche-toi avant qu'un autre qu arriver
là j'ai un grand qu'arrive débardeur
bronzé avec des muscles énorme et je
suis attirée du coin de l'oeil juillet
c'est bien un truc qui bouge
je suis en 2004 en suède ou encore mi
figue mi raisin un peu comme vous gâté
par la nature je veux truqués truc qui
bouge alors je vais pas y arriver toi
lui c'est que tu déjà là depuis
longtemps et je le regarde qui sait que
c'est à côté de moi bob sinclar non ah
ouais le dj bob sinclar
avec ce beau frère de 6 à 2 les mecs ils
mixent pas tout seul
m
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fait trente ans le football j'en ai
mais dans les douches des stations j'en
ai vu des gars à nabeul elle tombe
partie rentrer chez lui j'étais encore
là puissent auditeurs